well there weren't many new
anti-terrorism powers announced by the
prime minister but then he did say he
wanted the uk government's response to
the emerging threat from the terror
group islamic state in iraq and syria to
be considered and not knee-jerk however
there are a few things in this
announcement which will be welcomed by
the police and the security services in
the uk
requiring all airlines who operate out
of the uk to provide the authorities
here with advanced passenger information
can be extremely helpful in the efforts
to determine who might be planning to
travel overseas for the purposes of
terrorism an advanced list of names can
be checked against terror watch lists
and other databases
enhanced powers to seize suspects
passports will also be welcomed by the
authorities in the uk although there are
powers under the royal prerogative to
confiscate someone's passport it is a
fairly cumbersome power and it can't be
applied in real time by police and
border officials who might be suspicious
about a specific passenger
just before they're about to embark on a
flight that new power will enable them
to do that
but with around 500 british nationals
who've already traveled to syria and
iraq there remain significant concerns
about what happens on the return the
government is actively looking at
introducing targeted discretionary
powers to enable the uk to exclude
british nationals from returning to the
uk if it's believed they pose a threat
however this is a difficult prospect
both ethically and legally such a power
would effectively render any uk national
excluded from returning to the country
stateless now that law would undoubtedly
be challenged in the courts and getting
the liberal democrats on board seems
unlikely
so at this stage it's difficult to see
how the government will be able to enact
that final measure